um
okay so
first thing that i want to do is just
get into definition of roles which
is not too much except that
representative walper has very
graciously agreed uh to be
the the clerk for the subcommittee so we
thank him for that and he kind of has a
groove
going from that for the work that he
does with the regular committee um
aside from that as we go forward this is
not a public hearing or anything of that
nature this is this is
is it too much away from you
closer
how's that better
okay
i do project but
so
but because this is a work session the
intention here is to
go through uh address some of the
concerns that were brought up with
respect to the testimony on the bill
and actually go through brainstorming
and working through
how we can address any of those concerns
overcome them with the intention of
developing potentially some future
legislation that the next legislature
can act on so that being said
it's a very dynamic thing we're going to
have a lot of discussion within the
members of the committee itself
but a lot of the subject experts are you
guys that are out there sitting in the
chairs and so
um
if we get to a point in the agenda where
we're discussing something and you have
did i lose it if you have input with
respect to hey i have some data here
that would help inform why this is or is
not or if you have insights into how we
might form an approach to to tackling a
problem
then
raise your hand and i i anticipate
people will be coming in and out of the
discussion as we go forward
can you hear me now jen it looks like it
died again okay so she's adjusting
so that being said i just want to kind
of give a quick review of where the
committee basically was following the
public hearing so the public hearing
the
the bill itself was um
removing the remit the right of removal
from the respondent to the superior
court and basically holding that just
for the claimant and we heard a lot of
testimony and the testimony really
indicated that new hampshire was only
one of two states that allows removal by
the respondent and when it has been
challenged in the records
the courts have have not held in favor
of that so
we felt
that the bill
was on
pretty solid legal footing
from that perspective however um as we
heard testimony and a lot of folks that
had concerns with the bill they were
bringing up concerns in a lot of other
areas and the committee really felt a
little bit nervous
about approving the legislation at that
time based on those concerns
and also felt that there was an
opportunity to maybe identify some of
the issues with the human rights
commission
and you know provide some legislative
help um if if that will help kind of
shore things up as we go forward and so
really
from my perspective and we can kind of
talk about that i think that is where
the committee was and that is why they
decided to go forward with the interim
study
session
and so um that's kind of where i'm at
with that before i go on to looking at
the scope
does anybody else have any additional
thoughts with respect to that or
would like to add anything to that
mr chairman
yes representative
there you go nice job
uh yeah it seems to me that what we
really got from the hearings
was
there's a lot of issues with
how these cases are handled especially
the timeliness of it
and so
that's one of the things that i think we
should be spending some time
investigating and seeing if we can come
up with some kind of way
of expediting this because when we're in
three years five years
to me that's just totally unacceptable
it's it's it's
it's maybe worse than nothing
yeah so that that was definitely one of
the concerns the other concerns was with
the due process and
that if the right of removal was taken
away
are you taking away some of the due
process rights of the respondents i i
think the process is pretty robust but
definitely i think that is something
that we have to consider because it was
a concern that was brought up and
reinforced many times so
if you go down to the next bullet
on the agenda
basically and i put question marks on
these um because these were these were
just my thoughts and i i just want to
throw this you know first out to the
members of the committee but also out to
uh the folks in the audience
you know just based on some of the
comments from representative walper and
the testimony we heard
really to get by in here
the big concerns i heard was due process
so i think
from my perspective i would like to have
the committee look at that i don't think
that there is a guarantee
to a jury trial i don't think that due
process always rises to that level
but what is the due process in this case
and what is the standard for saying that
that is adequate due process or not due
process
so kind of understanding that
and also representative walper as you
brought up the timeliness
we did hear testimony about three years
we did hear testimony about five years
so the question is
what were the circumstances in those
cases
were those the average
uh median were those outlier situations
what kind of drove
those episodes and so i think you know
understanding is that the norm is that
an outlier if it is an outlier what
drove that outlier those are some of the
things i think
that we need to understand um
if we're going to go and really move
forward to a solution so
um
so
due process timeliness again i'll throw
it out to the rest of the committee
um i don't want to
blow the scope out too far
but
does anybody have any additional
thoughts or concerns something beyond
rosanna smith
thank you so much mr chair and i look
forward to working with my colleagues on
this um
i
am aware and i think
um
i'm not alone in being aware that some
of the problems
um
that the commission for human rights are
facing in new hampshire are being faced
in other states also
and
how
those down in terms of whether they are
state specific
or whether they have to do with the
organizational structure
of each of the commissions in the states
or
as we all know when they say it's not
about the money it usually is about the
money whether it has to do with that
i don't know the answers to any of those
questions
but if what we are looking at is a
rather than
a
narrow problem
a more targeted problem dealing with due
i'm in a
a state of
well a lack of clarity as to
whether any of those
broader issues
have any relevance
the last thing i want to do is to focus
on a broad issue and then miss the
opportunity
to focus on issues very narrow and
specific to new hampshire
i just
feel better by sharing my concern
so
is your concern just trying to
understand where new
hampshire uh
sits relative to the other states um
or or
mr chair that might be a very good way
of looking at it
um
and the purpose in looking at it that
would way not would not be because
misery loves company
but it would be because we might um
learn
from the experience
of other states about how to find our
way
through
uh so i thank you for making some sense
well i i think it's a good comment
because it it it is uh
how do we approach it what are other
states doing um
so is your thinking if we were to look
at it relative to
other states is that a whole separate
agenda item that you would look at just
in general or would you like to look at
it to say for example due process
how do other states process their claims
versus
how does our state process their claims
how do they render their decisions
versus how do we render our decisions
what are their timelines and what are
their relative resources which i think
would get at the time in this issue so
do you think
that
comparative analysis of other states
versus our state would fall within the
scope of looking at you know the process
and time in this issue or do you think
it should
be expanded beyond that what are your
thoughts
well i think it makes sense to see how
other states are handling
these two issues but that still leaves
on the table
and maybe it should be left on the table
i don't know
whether we're missing something
that is even more relevant
to what the commission for human rights
is facing then due process and
timeliness and i don't know the answer
mr chairman and i last thing i want to
do
is bury us in so much um
material that we're paralyzed and that
we're incapable of moving forward and so
that is really my concern which is why i
like your approach because it's narrow
it's focused and we know their problems
i guess at some point
i'd i'd like to have an asterisk
that says
or recognizing that we might
find that our attention would be better
focused
in another area so we wouldn't begin
with that but if somehow something
rears its ugly head and it would be an
ugly head
um
we shouldn't pretend it's not there
well what i think i mean i think there's
validity in that but
i i do think you know keeping a an
initially
focused
lens
based on some of the concerns raised in
the testimony but
part of that could be and we do have a
whole summer where we can after jen goes
to scotland and comes back we could
we could maybe do a comparative analysis
you know looking at process
and obviously
our initial goal with looking at process
is going to be understanding the due
process is it adequate
but from that comparative analysis other
things may come out um
which may inform us and give us
something else but i think
um maybe that might be a good way to
kind of thread that needle um
i think that makes a lot of sense i do
have one comment i don't know why we all
believe it or not it's on my bucket list
mr chairman
um yes
um you know when i was
looking at the bill you know
to prepare for the study committee i
kind of like i went kind of like around
in circles because i did research a
couple of states and
just basically um what i found was that
other states are having the very very
same issue um and so before getting lost
in that little loop i just thought no go
back to the bill focus on you know the
question
questions of due process end of um
i just wanted to follow up on
what representative smith was saying
because
the
broad concepts of due process or
or
timeliness
by analogy i i guess if
well
i'm more mechanical so if
if um
it's i don't think we need to be so
concerned about how the vehicle looks or
how fast it goes or what it sounds like
i think we actually have to
look at the mechanics of the build
and how it's working and
from my perspective you know from the
testimony that we heard
the delay in large part goes to the
mechanics
how the commission is working and i
guess
that's what i'd like to do some
diagnosis of is why
i was surprised at the number of
hearings and why there aren't more
hearings
more frequently
and who's hearing those hearings
and why is there such a delay in
scheduling hearings
so
i guess
rather and i i like the approach in
terms of the issues and i agree with the
issues of due process and timeliness but
i'd sort of like to get into the
mechanics and how that system is working
and how we might be able to
either
modify it or
so
when you're looking at mechanics though
you're still looking at mechanics to
basically accelerate the process
and
but you want to understand the process
what's
how does it go
who's hearing what and when
right i mean we we heard testimony over
and over again
uh in
no offense to anybody but that that the
system currently as it's structured is
dysfunctional
in that it takes so long to process
a case
that
uh by the time by the time you get a
decision
a an employee is already disenfranchised
so
it seems to me that
we
if
it
it may take more than just simply trying
to speed up the process it
it may take
a redesign of the process to make that
happen
and i and i don't disagree that we can
look at other places you know
we just saw an article from
massachusetts having the same problems
apparently that we're having here
uh and and maybe it's endemic
but
it seems to me that we ought to come up
with a new hampshire solution that works
thank you representative i have a
question mr chairman yes um
would it be helpful um to have a
a performance audit by the legislative
budget assistant would this be under
that purview
i would deflect that question to
representative smith
maybe in her capacity as a former
finance chair may know that better than
i
well that's always a good suggestion
there is um
a procedure for doing that there's a
committee
that
that screens requests from legislators
and then makes suggestions
to
staff and they take a look and see if it
if
how you would effectively design all of
that is good
but that takes a lot of time too and at
this point
in terms of um
direct uh
our action and
is somewhat limited i mean come november
1st we don't exist anymore
for this
committee um
there's no question that we could
include in our report um
that we think it would be helpful
and then
to have such an audit and then that
could go forward but it's nothing that
we can do now
before
many months pass
thank you representative lorenzo
anybody else have any thoughts or
comments with respect is anybody uh
in the galley
any thoughts comments with respect to uh
yes
okay
oh there it is
um
there has recently been an article
discussing the problems at the
massachusetts
commission against discrimination
i don't think that the problem that
they're experiencing is the same
as the one that we're experiencing here
in new hampshire though and that's
because in massachusetts the defendant
does not have this right of removal
so
imagine you're an employee
in
trying to work their way through the
process at mcad
you may
be mired
in a long investigative process
that's not
working
very
efficiently
and promptly
for several years until you get a pc
finding
but at least at the end of that process
you're not going to get yanked to
superior court to start all over again
period
but that's what's happening here in new
hampshire in new hampshire employees are
stuck
at the commission
trying to help
overburdened investigators for a long
time
and then they finally get a pc finding
and the defense defense uh council
because they can
okay sorry uh instead of pc probable
cause in mcat is the massachusetts
commission against discrimination anyway
i i i what i'm proposing is that the
situation is worse here for employees
than it is in massachusetts that's all
that i wanted to
to uh
oh me i'm megan douglas i'm an attorney
at douglas land and garvey here in
concord
does anybody else have any other
importer thoughts
sorry i guess i'm turned on again i'm
heather burns
from upton and hatfield on center street
here in concord
and i've been practicing employment law
here in new hampshire for about 30 years
i went to the law school here in concord
i've done a lot of work over the years
with the human rights commission and i
think as to the timely issue that you
were asking about
i think that things have been made much
more difficult over time for the
commission
because they have so few investigators
they're down to four investigators
as well as the executive director and
the assistant executive director and i
think it just makes it difficult
to sort of timely do investigation of
these cases and so to me i think that's
really the number one answer to
why it's difficult i know that i
understand that they recently lost an
investigator so i think they had five
and then they went back down to four
there's a lot of cases that go through
the new hampshire human rights
commission and to have it really handled
by primarily for investigators just
makes it very challenging for them to
conduct investigations within the three
years
that comes under our statute in new
hampshire to have a claim
that could be filed in court under rsa
354-a
you have to be able to
file your claim in court within three
years if you can't file it within three
years you no longer have a claim under
the state statute and there's definitely
been instances in probably recent years
where the human rights commission cannot
render they can't finish their their
investigation and render the probable
cause finding within a three-year period
of time
so i do think lack of resources is an
issue and i'm happy to answer any other
questions you have because i have great
familiarity with practicing before
many many people before the human rights
thank you thank you does anybody have a
so i mean i think i think for me
that's a little bit at the heart of it
is it is it a question of mechanics is
it a question of resources
um
that's i think what we want to get into
so that we have a better understanding
of that and if it's a question of the
mechanics as representative gordon was
saying where can we shore that up if
it's a question of resources you know
what can we do in that area but but i
think
the role of this committee is to really
understand
those elements the resources the
mechanics so that whatever we recommend
is going to truly address uh the problem
so that that's our goal here so does
anybody else have any other thoughts um
just on the scope issue and and
broadly speaking where we should be
going
yes sorry i had one more comment that i
wanted to address um
about representative gordon's question
about why um there aren't really more
hearings being held at the commission
and
from my personal experience representing
a lot of complainants of the commission
i think that what happens is because it
takes the commission an awful long time
to conduct investigations of cases
a lot of employees who are represented
by counsel in cases by someone like
myself or megan douglas
we end up pulling those cases out of the
commission and we file them in court
ourselves on behalf of the complainant
because we're not sure that the
commission will be even able to conduct
an investigation within the three-year
time frame required by the statute
and then
for those complainants oftentimes
unrepresented who are the ones who do
wait out the commission process and they
wait for a full investigation for those
fortunate enough to get a probable cause
finding by the human rights commission
a lot of times at that point the
employer then takes the case and removes
them to court and starts the process all
over again we've had we've had
many potential plaintiffs contact our
law firm about cases where they've been
at the human rights commission three
four or so years excuse me they get a
probable cause finding and the reason
they're reaching out to our firm is that
as soon as they had a probable cause
finding and they were hoping that they
would be able to have a hearing before
the human rights commission the employer
then removes them to the superior court
and an unrepresented employee really
knows that it it's almost impossible for
he or she to succeed in the superior
court system if they're pro se and so
they're reaching out looking for a
lawyer but they're already at the point
where they've already been brought to
court so i think that's really the
answer as to why there's not all that
many hearings and when you look at how
many hearings the human rights
commission has held
i think that's why i think the lack of
hearings is that once there's a probable
cause finding
a lot of the time the employers remove
the case to superior court and say we're
not going to go through the hearing
process at all the commission
but obviously i'm happy to hear from the
commission i'm sure you'll want to hear
from the commission directly as well but
that's my perspective from getting uh
calls from clients and following the
commission thank you ms burns i saw
thank you um ani malachi from the human
rights commission
um okay so there are a lot of things
we're talking apples oranges pineapples
some things are apples by themselves
some things are oranges and some things
are fruit salad
so
with an understanding that there'll be a
lot of that as we work through and
understanding the mechanics of the
conversation is really important
one of the things that is also important
to note is
in terms of the last four years so we
can look back way into the beginning but
i've been there for the last four years
so one of the important things to look
at relative to hearings and the quote
unquote lack thereof if you look at the
document
for example
in the folder that you have
as soon as you open it on the left hand
side
it says new hampshire commission for
human rights white paper so if you just
skip to the very last page
or even if you look through
this
uh the the pages what you'll see is
all of the cases so this is from 20
fiscal year 2021.
if you look at the
the
cases that are named there those are
things that were scheduled for hearings
and what our pros part of our process is
there's mediation in the beginning an
off an opportunity for that
sometimes one party other or the other
doesn't want to which is their right
however once is a probable cause finding
then we move into what's called
conciliation which really is a mandatory
mediation same process
we had
last year or fiscal year 21 we were
scheduling
three of those a month but now we have
moved into
scheduling two a week in terms of
conciliations now
a hearing happens a hearing is scheduled
but the hearing happens
if one of several things doesn't happen
if the case does not conciliate
then it moves on to schedule a hearing
if the respondent withdraws it or if the
complainant withdraws it both of those
all three of those things happen
now we will and we literally had one
yesterday that was scheduled for a
hearing but it conciliated which means
that it settled so
for this fiscal year so far we have a 51
settle rate
for conciliated cases so there isn't a
need for the hearing if it settles
the commission has two
almost competing
factors it wants the individual that's
been aggrieved to be made whole if that
can be done through mediation or
conciliation great
and the con and the commission also
wants there to be no more discrimination
i'm sure we all want that sitting in
this room however we are not going to
not allow a complainant to
be made whole for the mere fact of us
having a hearing
so if they are if they agree to whatever
the terms are if the two parties can
come together great that person is made
whole and if you look at this document
there are a lot of the cases that
settled there are instances where
someone may have a marginal case someone
may have a very strong case and we have
heard this we'll say anecdotally that
they've gone to seek an attorney and the
attorney will not represent them until
they have gotten a probable cause
finding from us and so that process
takes it long takes as long as it takes
and then once they've received a
probable cause
there are times where they are more
likely to obtain an attorney to then
move it on in the process whether that
remains with us whether it goes to court
there are some there are some charges
that are you know just awful and very
easy to prove you've got a smoking gun
you've got text messages you have emails
you have a lot of evidence that makes it
easy to be able to prove that this thing
happened and unfortunately with these
incidents is and it's not like a car
wreck where there's debris left on the
street there are some issues where
there is a lot of he said she said and
there has to be either depositions or
our investigation in order to
substantiate whatever the claim is
whether the complainant whether this
actually happened to them or whether
there was a non-discriminatory reason
for whatever the action the adverse
action was
relative to the person filing the charge
so i know lots of fruit salad happening
here but i think all of those things are
representative smith
thank you very much for being here and
for sharing that with us
um
and i'm going to ask a difficult
question
and of course you don't have to answer
are you
satisfied
with how
the commission is structured
and how it is
carrying out
its uh functions
that is a really excellent and hard
question
there are a lot of parts to that and i
may have to look over at my attorney to
make sure i say this correctly
part of it is
so there are statutory reasons why we do
what we do as you well know
i mean i think the thing that would make
things move faster if there are if
people aren't allowed to
amend charges or you know those little
things well they're actually very big
things if i don't remember all of the
things in the beginning i can
continuously
amend my charge so every new amendment
which is that person's right at this
point that needs to be investigated so
if i am making a charge and i um if i'm
saying that two things happened and
actually there were four things now that
i remember and um and but we've already
started the investigation of the two
things and i want to add the other two
things that information then needs to go
to the respondent and they need time to
respond
okay so you seem to
feel that um
the first thing you would mention is
that
the
the statute or the rules i'm not sure
which because i'm not checking
um
should be changed to um
limit the um
uh
the complainant's uh right to amend
the complaint um no that's not what i'm
saying um it it is that individual's
right in any investigation to be able to
support whatever
whatever claims they're making just like
it's the right of the respondent to be
able to respond to those rights i think
what i'm really trying to say
is i don't know that there's anything
less that we can do if there's anything
based on how we do what we do any rights
that we could take away from someone to
more to expedite our process i mean
ultimately it's the number of the number
of cases that come in or the number of
charges that come in and the number of
people we have allocated to do the work
is is the is the issue
if i could
once more then
okay um if you're interested in taking
away
rights and i don't think you are you've
come to the wrong committee you know
i i feel quite confident that i could
speak to everybody on the committee in
saying that so let me try again
you have a very difficult position
you are in charge of a commission
uh the effects of
the work that you do
enhance or
the ability of those people both
employers and employees to carry on the
work that they're supposed to do i
understand it's a difficult job
i understand you have a budget that you
work for and you have i understand you
have the number of staff people that you
have
what i want to know is
when you go home at night
is there a time when you say
if
we could do this or if we could do that
or if we could make this change we could
better carry out
our responsibilities
i i understand what the situation is not
great what i want to know is how can we
change the situation if we're going to
keep everything the way it is and have
no recommendations for change then we
can all go outside and enjoy the lovely
day
um
you are in the position to know more
than we
what changes could
or should be made so that you could
better carry out your obligations
can you share anything with us or would
you just assume not
um
i would want to
look at a few other things that i could
potentially suggest um one of the things
to to immediately answer the question um
one of the things that we did do as an
as an organization is look at the
internal sort of the administrative
process of our case processing to see
where we could um cut out any
inefficiencies to be able to move cases
i hate to say faster
but you're still doing the due process
you're you're not shortcutting anything
but what were we doing inside if
anything that needed to be amended or
changed or
shortened in our process and we've made
those changes um and so
cases are moving along internally faster
ultimately the answer really is going to
be
those things that i can't control inside
of the office and i'm not speaking
statutorily but looking at staff
the other things besides
simply in air quotes simply the case
work and the other part of our statute
is outreach education and training and
if we're doing more of that hopefully
then there are fewer cases if you're
reaching out and doing more of that work
then employers are clear
what it is that they need to do or
shouldn't do employees are clear what
they have access to and and what
responsibilities the employers are
what the things that they're responsible
for
maybe it's creative problem solving and
every business has a packet or something
through the secretary of state's office
that helps them understand what they're
supposed to do for their employees maybe
that's something we could do
but i mean
that's a long answer to a longer
question
and i'm happy to
to think through and spitball and we can
have conversations if it's allowed over
the course of the summer to come up with
different ideas i'm very open to that i
come in with an open hand
wanting to talk to you very
transparently about what we're doing how
we're doing it
what it looks like and if there are ways
for us to make this better then let's do
that
thank you representative smith
with
is
um thank you very much for the question
it really is resources um as was stated
before uh four we've hired another so we
have five which means we'll be fully
staffed as of this friday
so our full staff of investigators is
five investigators for the state
if there are more and i'm i'm certainly
putting in things this is a budget year
so i'm making my ask
but if there are more investigators then
there's an opportunity to
to
assign more cases which can then limit
how long someone is waiting prior to the
start of an investigation
so
could could it happen in a year sure it
absolutely could and it is required to
have more staff in order to process
those the way our process works is the
oldest case
that is waiting for assignment is then
assigned to an investigator the
expectation is at the bare minimum that
they finish that they complete four
cases a month
in terms of investigation that does not
include any cases that are settled
whether through mediation or concealed
well conciliation conciliated cases are
investigated but
any cases that are mediated so we offer
mediation from the very beginning you
know once people have gotten their
paperwork then we start offering
mediation which that has those numbers
that percentage has increased as well so
there are more cases closing whether
whether it's by mediation which is
before an investigation even starts or
after
um
having the additional staff does make a
difference because you can assign those
cases more of those cases out so there
are fewer hopefully people waiting
but it doesn't stop the number of cases
i believe
so far this year
yeah so so far
fiscal or calendar
fiscal so so far this state fiscal year
we've had over 900 inquiries to us so
that's not necessarily that's not going
to be a number of cases but people are
calling so
there's a lot of traffic that's coming
in the door having more staff to assign
cases to very important however that
doesn't stop the number of people that
are calling for information and those
people are businesses hey you know
there's someone here who needs an
accommodation what should i do
there are employees i asked for an
accommodation and i didn't get it what
do i do
and then there are people that are
certainly calling for training and so we
provide those trainings for those
individuals so
it is a matter of resources um i believe
where we are right now we have shored up
a lot of how we do our process
internally to streamline it
without without sacrificing
the complainant's opportunity to bring
additional
uh to amend their charges or bring
information in as well as we've not
sacrificed the respondents opportunity
to respond to those charges
but once we get into a case
you
the process is a little bit at the mercy
of the people responding to the request
okay
wait
so uh thank you for the follow-up the
five years outlier so let's just start
there
statutorily you have two years some have
been three years but the five-year case
that was testified before that that's an
outlier um could a system be designed so
that you could move through the system
so the so the other part is it's the
staffing that's missing if you're
waiting
and then once the case is assigned
you can move through that case in a year
some are fewer that summer some of it is
less than that
some could be a little more it depends
on how complex it is but i could say
that the year would could be an average
but you're going to have to wait
because of the staffing
and staffing not only means the number
of in
the number of investigators that we have
right now but it also deals with prior
to 2011
turnover from then to now so if there's
turnover if you have 25 cases and you
have 25 and you have 25 and you leave
whatever the reason you leave your case
load let's say you've completed five and
there's 20 that's now divided between
these two people so now they have 35
each
your cases may if they're older then
yours are going to be investigated first
that are that are distributed between
the other investigators so the ones that
now if there's a better way to do that
i'm open to it
it's just
if this one has been waiting longer
do you take the other one or do you take
the one that was yours
that now needs to be
yeah so
the uh so there's a couple of things
that there's the investigative element
that's ongoing but you also mentioned
that there's an education element an
intake element all of that stuff are
those handled by the same resources uh
is the cross over there or
are they in discrete buckets
thank you for the question um buckets so
the investigators specifically and only
do investigations
outreach education and training is
pretty much myself and the assistant
director
on top of the other things that we're
doing
intake we have an intake person it was a
part-time position and
that was
change so i changed that to be a
full-time position which it's vacant at
the moment so we are hiring for that
person but it is now a full-time and
then hopefully the part-time the
part-time position can um
in this upcoming budget would have the
funding put back so you'd have one and a
half people doing intake because of all
of what's involved there's that's that's
the first time anyone reaches us so
there's a lot of paperwork and there are
a lot of
processes involved in in taking that
information
tracking the information making sure
it's put into what if we take the charge
put into our system properly so
so that the investigator will have
everything that they need once a case is
assigned
and so it's my understanding as well
that there was work done with you and
the attorney general to kind of optimize
the mechanics of the process um is that
to kind of
talk to representative gordon's concern
that happened recently and has that been
implemented um so uh
what we what we did as a as a unit as an
as an agency um prior to the group
meeting um i jill perlow was our
client's client services representative
um jill perlow and i did a lot of work
on looking at the statute looking at our
rules looking at our process to see
where we could
make some time savings where we could be
more efficient
and also
sean locke who's now our
client services representative was a
part of that process as well and we
walked through so i created sort of what
i thought with their assistance and then
walk through that process with the staff
to see um because they're they're going
to have to use this
how how does this work will this is this
better um
what changes can we make based on what
you're seeing uh to make the effect to
make it more efficient and they had
suggestions on the report writing which
is significantly shorter but still has
quality information so that someone
who's not represented can understand
whether why their case uh why their
charge was probable cause or not
probable not probable cause
and so i feel very secure in what we've
walked through and with their assistance
to make sure that we were legally doing
everything that we should be doing while
still trying to find any time savings
that we could for the entire process
so um and we're not going to go through
all of this here because obviously we're
going to have the whole summer to kind
of allow things to germinate a bit but
in in the discussions that you were
having with that team
um
where they're because you're basically
doing that within your own rule-making
power but
were there statutory barriers that you
came up against during that process and
that evaluation where you said you know
we don't know if this makes sense or
works and that's a statutory area where
if that could maybe be revisited
that's another opportunity to optimize
the process was any discussion going on
in that area um yes there are a couple
of the letters that we write um that we
send out that provide for more time for
final answers um and so actually what we
did was we just moved that particular
that particular letter that's sent out
to both parties
up sooner so that it wouldn't hinder
the report writing and the conclusion um
i don't know
i it would take a smarter person than me
with a esquire after their name to
determine if it is a due process issue
excuse me if we removed that letter all
together
that was one of the things that we
wanted to really think through to make
sure that in our quest to have time
savings and to be more efficient that we
were not limiting someone's due process
and i believe
that was why we said well we won't
change that because you know we have a
rule we have rules that need to be
updated as well and that's certainly
something we could fix in our rules but
if i remember correctly we didn't want
to make that change because we didn't
want
the person to not have the opportunity
and it's called a summation letter and
the attorneys here will know what i'm
speaking of um attorney douglas and
attorney burns um so
to to not take away the right of the
person to have that letter we just moved
it a little sooner in the process so
that
everything could be submitted in enough
time to
to complete a report
i would need to
and that that's a good question i would
need to sit and look at it from a stance
of removing if there's anything that we
don't really need because it's not not
taking away rights but something that's
maybe more obsolete
and could be gotten rid of because it
doesn't really add to the process
i would have to look with those eyes
because when we went through the process
we weren't necessarily looking to remove
things we were looking to
move things potentially so that the
process would move faster if that makes
sense
representative smith thank you very much
could i just repeat the chair's question
and it doesn't need a long answer in
your work with
the people who were helping you on this
did you find anything you can just say
yes or no really did you find anything
that
you recognized
could improve the situation if the
and you don't have to answer or you
could say you don't know
i'll say i don't know for right now
because thank you there's a lot of
pieces perfect thank you
representative dilorenzo uh thank you mr
chair um miss malachi um
my question is around um
whether cases are ever triaged
and i ask because i realize that some
complaints
of discrimination are more egregious
and i would not
expect
in the railroad i would not expect those
cases to go
in the bottom of the pile or you know as
its turn comes up could you respond to
that please um yes thank you
um historically what we have done is
things as they come in
they are
they they move forward as their co as
they come in
if there's someone who has
uh let's say there's a sexual harassment
situation where there is a crime that's
committed that person has more than just
rights with us so they can certainly
file a police report and they can
continue to move forward with us as well
and there's a recommendation while we
will absolutely take the charge
that they also go to the police
department
no to answer the question we have not
triaged cases because
there's been uh quite the the backlog to
the thought has been to move this one
ahead
of someone who's been waiting six months
or whatever the time frame um but if
it's something that is criminal and
innate criminal in nature
we will absolutely
still take the charge but refer
them or make the suggestion that they
check with the police as well
if there's something that's particularly
heinous then we would talk to the ag's
office to see
how do we how do we
move this one ahead
of someone else when you have other
attorneys attorneys will talk right so
you'll know that i've moved your case
ahead and they will know that i've moved
your case ahead of of them and they've
been in waiting longer so we would ask
for what guidance we would need to be
able to do that if if there was a case
that was particularly heinous
as far as
handling cases
and shuttling them to other places for
instance i understand that
the human rights commission
does housing
discrimination
deals with housing discrimination um
complaints on behalf of hud
um
does
what about
an employment complaint could that be
shuttled
from the eeoc or to the eeoc
thank you for the question so currently
we do not have a hud contract so
we because statutorily we we cover
housing we can take a housing case we do
give people the opportunity to go
directly to hud should they choose their
timeline is different
for eeoc because we have a work sharing
agreement with them
we take the case on behalf of the eeoc
depending on the number of employees and
then it's dual filed
usually the way it works is because our
statute is a shorter time so 180 days
we'll take it if it's anything more than
180 days up to 300 days someone would
file with the eeoc
and then they would investigate their
case if someone goes to the eeoc
sometimes they'll reach out to us and
say hey this person filed there in new
hampshire and they'll refer it back to
us and sometimes they'll continue
they'll keep the case
then a follow-up second follow-up at any
time did the um
human rights commission have an
agreement with hud on cases um yes prior
to 2000 i believe i think there was a
rule change
or excuse me
a statutory change with hud and the
commission fell out of um
alignment with those federal rules and
it's called substantial equivalency and
so
we are currently working with hud so
last session
there was a piece of legislation i
believe it was sb 126 that finally was
able to there were several tries last
year it was accomplished the rule the
statute was changed as it relates to
housing to allow us to move forward with
beginning the conversation for a work
sharing agreement with hud so we're
thank you for
thank you mr chair and thanks for taking
my question the
the
uh
i'm presuming that if it
because it's a commission that the
commissioners are the ones who are
actually hearing the hearings themselves
is that correct that is correct
and
is that an issue at all with regard to
scheduling commissioners for hearings is
there any delay created by that
um thank you for the question um
there is there hasn't been uh what we'll
do is schedule three hearings or three
possible
hearings for one particular month and
then it's always three commissioners
that are the hearing panel
and it cannot be the commissioner who
made the decision on the case
what has routinely happened is those
cases will either settle
or removed by respondent or
or removed by complainant so
we have
we don't have
a lot of hearings
of course this law could change that and
we would have more hearings
and that would be something we would
if i could just follow up so
you indicate you're having three
hearings per month is
is that because we set the number at
three hearings or does that
is that the adequate number to
to hold all the hearings um i apologize
three we schedule three per month
and what will happen is those three will
routinely
settle or they are removed by either
respondent or complainant so we don't
actually we will not have three per
month
we schedule three and then they're
either they they disappear in a good way
i get that they
you're scheduling three per month in the
hopes that we'll have at least one
potentially
potentially one hearing but
that takes care of
scheduling three months takes care of
all your hearings so you don't have any
um i'm not sure that i understand the
question so so just to maybe so is your
question representative gordon is the
three hearings per month because that's
required what's required to clear the
cases or is that because you're resource
constrained
and so how where do you come at the the
three
cases per month
well there's there's a lot of runway
that goes with that so before the case
before something is scheduled for a
hearing you know once the report is
complete
and
and then there's conciliation that's
scheduled because you you have to so
that's then scheduled the if the person
is represented whether both sides
sometimes both parties are represented
sometimes it's one so there's scheduling
that has to take place if they're
sometimes attorneys that's not their
only client so they may have depositions
they may be in court people are on
vacation a variety of things happen so
as soon as possible uh conciliation is
scheduled and then if the conciliation
fails
then we move on and schedule the hearing
but the parties can still be talking in
the background even if the conciliation
fails so it's not just a one and done so
we had a conciliation yesterday if it
didn't if it didn't um if it didn't
settle then we would have had the
pre-hearing conference to get that on
the calendar but the two parties can
still talk and then even though it's
scheduled they could still
settle and then it removes itself and
then it's off the calendar
but if there was a surge coming down the
pipeline for example
um in that situation okay we have a big
surge coming would you schedule five to
say you know
or would you say no we are resource
limited we can only schedule the three
even with that surge coming down the
pipeline um that's a really good
question i i think we would have to look
at it to figure out what's the right
amount to schedule to make sure that um
we would be serving the surge right so
if if using your hypothetical example if
five is the right number then we would
schedule five but we would still be
doing all of the behind-the-scenes work
there would still be conciliations there
would just have to be more of them
um and to to to go from that way or we
would look at
with with the ag's office if there was a
rules change that we needed to make or a
statutory change to support that then we
would have that conversation sooner
rather than later obviously and then
speak with you all if there are changes
that we needed statutorily do we need to
have an alj do we need to do something
different that's not something that we
do i don't know but but as but as it
stands right now to kind of get
representative gordon's question if you
see a surge coming down the pike and
you've got a schedule five you're going
to do what you have to do to schedule
the five and you know so it's not fixed
in stone that it's going to be three no
it's not
just one quick question
from a process perspective so
the
the commissioner who's investigating
they make the probable cause
determination and then it goes on for
the final resolution and that's where
the other three commissioners come in
who conducts the conciliat the
conciliation
uh
is i'm presuming that
if it's a mediation that there's some
mediator is that an employee of the
commission who who does that yes that
beautiful woman sitting right over there
does our conciliations
and when she is not in the office for a
little while i will be handling them
okay and
is that for all of them this one person
does all of them correct
we do them in person or we do them
virtually we have we can or we can do a
hybrid
i'm always confused but the
the
you we talked about different buckets
and
the fact that you're getting 600
inquiries coming in just asking
questions but that's a different group
of people that are
involved in that's they're in a
different bucket that's a different
group of people
than the people who are actually doing
the litigation process
and
and you indicated that you're doing
training
and i guess that was the question if
if they're separate buckets
to the extent you're getting these 600
inquiries that's not affecting the
timing of the litigation process itself
correct so the intake coordinator
is handling those intake phone calls
those i have a question regardless of
who it's from and it's also i think i
have a charge so it's all of that so all
of that is considered intake
every call that comes in does not
manifest manifest itself into an actual
charge so
you know so the there's all of that is
in one bucket but that's the intake
person that is not an investigator
that's doing that work
and that's not
the assistant director or myself so they
are somewhat separated if if i'm
so um i think
that's been a very good discussion but
what i'd like to do now
is just kind of get into having fleshed
that out a little bit
just kind of talk through
um
so we we talked a little bit about the
mechanics
and
how can the mechanics be shored up
there's been work that's been done uh
with the commission and the attorney
general
are there legislative elements that we
can do to help other resource elements
so i think the question now is
in order to get
a better view
of exactly what is needed
what kind of information do we want to
kind of gather so that when we come back
in september we have that in front of us
so what what do we think that the
approach should be
with respect to that
well i do okay
so
i think the first thing that i would
want to have is a clear picture of
what's going on
i hear 900
inquiries this fiscal year
i hear three hearings a month i hear
conciliation has to happen i have this
report that says cases are settling
and being removed
i'd like to have a much clearer
breakdown of if we got 900 phone calls
how many of those end up in charges how
many of those charges end up
you know
because
like the hrc may be drinking from a fire
hose
and if that's the case then
that's something that needs to be
addressed
not in the cur at the in the present
moment
by
um
well it'd be it'd end up being a
staffing issue right now
as opposed to or maybe there was
something that we could do that would be
changing the process but uh i think
there's been a lot of work already done
on that from what i've already heard
um so that'd be that's that's the first
thing i want to have i want to be able
to get a grasp on
what's the scope of this
and it's one thing to hear the five your
case is an outlier
and there's a three-year window and
people are removing
things from the hrc because of the
three-year window
but
i don't have any idea of
how this is actually working
and and and the relative
where these numbers take us
uh representative smith
thank you very much mr chairman mr
chairman i would like to go back perhaps
an hour
to a question that representative
dilorenzo
raised
and
i
perhaps glibly said well this is the
process this had to do with the
legislative budget audit
and
listening now for an hour to um comments
from attorneys who have
been involved with the commission
and to the um articulate comments um
of uh
the captain of the ship so to speak
um i would like to make a suggestion
and uh
that is
that
this
subcommittee
without any
delay
to
the joint committee
on
legislative audits
and the fiscal committee
and
the
lba
so that everybody knows
draft a letter saying that based on what
we have heard
we
believe that in order to
intelligently
suggest what legislative actions
could or should be taken
to
make the commission function
optimally
that we
try to put in place as soon as possible
um
a performance audit not not a financial
audit but a performance audit
of the commission
we understand that um
you know the full
legislature isn't
going to meet again until the fall but
we do not need
full
legislative
we do not have fill legislative action
for this to happen
because the legit the joint committee
makes a suggestion to the fiscal
committee the fiscal committee
asks the lba
is this something that's doable all that
could take place between now
and the fall
which isn't to say the audit would take
place between now and fall but at least
we could start the process because i
came in here this morning
thinking having read the agenda thinking
it would make sense to focus on
the areas that the chair of the
subcommittee identified
but now
realizing that the situation
is
different
whether it's more complicated less
complicated i don't know but it's
different from one that could be
[Music]
resolved by addressing
timeliness and due process
and so i think that as usual
representative dilorenzo had a very
so what would they be doing
process wise
between now and the fall if we were to
draft such a letter
um they you know the fiscal committee
meets all summer
um and uh
they meet once a month but they meet
all summer um they could start the
process
uh rather than if they if they thought
that it was appropriate they could start
the process rather than wait
until january to
um
have a new legislature
i don't know what's on
the lba agenda i don't know how many
other
performance audits are ahead
um
of you know
you have priorities on the list
but
i'm not sure that no matter what a good
job we do on timeliness
cut to the chase so to speak so
the performance audit what kind of
output would be in that what data would
we get from that oh have you never seen
a performance audit
representative mclean
you have been denied one of the greatest
resources available to the new hampshire
legislature
in
the audit division of highly trained and
skilled people
would take the question that came to
them from the legislature
would
do their own
initial research based on the rsas and
and uh
rules
and discussing with the agency identify
areas
that need
um further look
and they will using a number of
resources available to them
really do a thorough investigation of
how the organization is structured how
it carries at its mandate um
how it holds itself responsible how the
broader government
holds the agency responsible all of
those things
with always suggestions
for
how to address the concerns
and um
i would urge you
to
contact michael kane who is the our
legislative budget analyst ask him to
give you some examples
of
a relevant performance audits so that
you can get a better sense and i think
that knowing your background and knowing
your interest in just the facts ma'am
that um
you are
going to fall in love
mr chairman um
a couple of years ago the house
judiciary committee um
and i believe it was with criminal
justice committee um we
had we reviewed the audit from the for
the
parole board and it was really
interesting it was like a lot of work
very interesting um
great process and
the person who did the audit is very
very very knowledgeable about you know
policy and procedure and
stuff like that but
so i mean we could certainly draft such
a letter and i'll
do some follow-up with you on that um
would it make sense to continue to
gather our own data though in tandem
with that i think yes oh i would think
so i would think so because um so
you know
and we might in the end when we gather
that data see some things that we could
suggest for future legislation right
away
and we we ought to do that if we can but
meantime i think we would be
to help us
get to um a position where where
we're
giving approp
appropriate attention to a very
important
part of our state government which is
the commission on human rights
okay
yes uh
could you go to the table please because
and turn on the mic because this is
being
videoed and people can't hear you
otherwise
thank you representative smith thank you
representative mclean for the record
for the record marissa chase executive
director of the new hampshire
association for justice i know you've
all been drinking from a fire hose over
this past hour and a half but i just
wanted to make sure that you knew
you know we talked a little bit about
the due process issue but
megan and heather have done some
research on that i didn't know if you
wanted to hear about that today
and i believe they did want to respond
to
some of the prior conversation i just
don't know what your schedule and
timeline is like whatever obviously
so if ms burns wants to come up and
would be great perhaps they could both
come up together is that okay with you
it's fine with me if it's fine with them
thank you very much again
i just wanted to answer one of the
questions that you'd had a moment ago
before there was the suggestion and
discussion of the performance audit um
and that was you were sort of asking
about sort of almost the light life
cycle of a case that goes through the
commission and i just wondered if i
might help at least from the plaintiff's
perspective explain how the process does
happen and i don't know the absolute
full internal workings of the commission
but you heard from the executive
director so she's told you a little bit
about it but just in terms of the whole
life cycle it seemed like a lot of the
questions we were getting
made it sound like you sort of thought
that things were getting bogged down by
the time you get to the hearing process
and from my perspective i don't really
think that's what's happening i think
that the bogging down is not happening
by the time you get to the hearings and
so i don't think it matters whether
there's that the commission can do three
hearings a month or five hearings a
month the question is how long does it
take to have an investigation done in
the process because essentially this is
what happens you file um you file a
charge if you're an unrepresented person
you call their phone number and you get
that intake person that that executive
director molokai was talking about and
then they would prepare a charge for you
and send it out to you and if it looks
correct then you sign it in front of a
notary and then you file with the
commission oftentimes if you're
represented by an attorney the
attorney's office prepares the charge
and it gets filed in the commission in
the same way you have to sign in front
of a notary
saying that it's true and accurate
then it gets filed
and from the plaintiff's perspective
that's sort of when the waiting game
begins because it takes a very long time
for the case to even get to the point
where it can be assigned to an
investigator and we monitor cases that
we have in the commission
it can often take more than a year
sometimes more than 18 months for the
case to even get assigned to an
investigator so from our perspective
that's where the process is is just
getting bogged down and again i think
it's because of the lack of the
investigative resources because
that's the most that's the piece that
the
human rights commission from the
employment cases spends its most time
doing is is doing the investigation so
you have to wait for the case to get
inside to an investigator
then the investigator is assigned the
only other thing that really happens
during that whole process is after the
complaint is first filed a letter gets
sent out asking for the respondent to
file a response to the charge and
usually they're given i believe it's 60
days to do that and sometimes they ask
for an additional 30 days
but it doesn't really make a difference
even if there's that slight delay at
that point in the process because then
you're in a big waiting game waiting
for the case to be assigned to an
investigator and that's what takes
really the most time is between the time
that the response to the charge gets
filed then for the case to have to get
assigned to an investigator and then for
the investigator to do the investigation
and write up the investigation once
there's a write-up of the investigation
it's our understanding that it then goes
to the investigating commissioner to
make a determination on on probable
cause or no probable cause and then once
that happens then the probable cause of
the no probable cause finding is sent
out there is something called a
summation letter that gets sent out
before it goes to to the commissioner
just essentially telling the parties
the sort of an overview of what has been
done in the investigation
so that if the parties have additional
information they want to give to the
commission they have time to do that
so that is how the process works from
our perspective i hope that's helpful to
you to just sort of understand the life
cycle of of how one of these cases goes
and i'm happy to answer any questions as
i am able
well i uh thank you for your input i i
was kind of sort of piecing that
together through the testimony but i
think it would be helpful and to kind of
follow up on what representative wolper
was asking for me
not being a lawyer but being a person
who makes light bulbs
you know
being able to look at a process
and map the process and that might be
one of the things that we asked the
director to do over the summer is put
together a map of the process so that we
can understand
where all those pieces to get together
and visually so that i'm not kind of
drawing back on this memory but if we
could put that together
and just say okay this is step one step
two step three what's involved in that
and also
it would be interesting to understand um
what is
are the average times and what is
driving some of those outliers so
representative walpole was talking about
well there's an intake of 900 cases
how does that break down
and for those
cases that fall outside of
the the normal like what is what is the
average and for those cases that fall
outside of the norm
what is the breakdown on those um and is
it indeed from the intake step and i
think that will
drive us all to the mechanics side or to
the resource side
but i think from my perspective
um having just a process flow where we
kind of look at each step it's mapped
out for us and we understand
what those outputs are so we
we have a better understanding for what
is the norm
because we keep hearing three years and
five years and we really want to get to
is that the norm is that the outlier and
what is driving those outliers because i
think that's important so that would be
information in addition to the fiscal
audit uh
that performance i wrote it down
i wrote with the big p in there
okay so um
that would be
useful information to have so
mr chair could could i just ask a yes
question
attorney burns you mentioned the
waiting a year to get an investigator
once an investigator is assigned
what might typically be the time frame
for them to make a probable cause
determination
i can honestly tell you in the past few
years it can take more than three years
to get to the point where you get to a
probable cause finding because we've had
cases that have been in the process of
being investigated at the commission
where we have ended up having to pull
them out of the commission just before
the three-year statute of limitations
because if we don't do that then we lose
our claim under our state
anti-discrimination statute rsa 354-a a
complainant has to file the suit in
court within three years and we have had
several cases where we could not get a
finding within that
three-year time frame and therefore we
had to pull the case out and file i have
not had an experience of five years and
i do a tremendous amount of employment
work but i i certainly have had three
so i think could i could i just
oh
well
did you want to comment on that or i
just wanted to
put a little more meat on what heather
just explained
heather i you'll correct me if i'm wrong
but
you could let
um that three year deadline
to file in superior court lapse
but the problem with that is is that you
then you then
roll the dice on getting a
p a probable cause finding or or a no
probable cause finding if you get a
probable cause finding
then
in my experience the defense defendants
counsel is going to remove you to
superior court
anyway
if you get a no probable cause finding
then then the employees um
[Music]
done in terms of relief except unless
they have grounds for appeal to uh you
know grounds
to appeal the quality of the
investigation or the application
misapplication of law in the
investigation
giving rise to the no probable cause
finding
so i
heather did i i mean is it just accurate
okay
and could i just follow up with with
attorney burns on the so
there's a substantial period of time
it's taking them to make a determination
with regard to probable cause and
typically
probable cause is
a standard that's
somewhere more than a reasonable
suspicion but
less than more likely than not which is
that's what our supreme court says
so
but what i'm gathering is
this determination of probable cause is
more than
what you would see in a criminal context
of a determination of probable cause
than you might otherwise see is is that
a fair representation it's hard to say i
i will i will say first off i don't do
any criminal work at all so what
probable cause honestly means um in the
criminal context i'd have to go back
more than 30 years to when i was in law
school
i don't dare do that um
but
i i i can't say that i can give you a
black and white answer as to what
probable cause means and i would i would
prefer honestly to defer to either um
executive director malachi or assistant
executive director
burke cohen because i think that
depending on if you asked a plaintiff's
attorney or a defendant's attorney you
might get a different view on what
probable cause is but certainly if
attorney douglas has a comment i'm happy
to let her
the commission does have a rule defining
probable cause and i'm gonna state it as
close to
the exact language that i can recall
here today
it is um
sufficient facts in the record from
which a reasonable fact finder
could find
discrimination afoot
so that's that's the test that the
investigator is looking to see whether
there's sufficient facts in the records
for a reasonable commissioner
to conclude that discrimination happened
and i i'm i'm open to rebuttal if
i've
anybody else have any additional
thoughts
so like i said i
i would like to see um a timeline just
so it it kind of
gives us a better
a visual depiction of the process i
think is going to be easier for us
rather than trying to pull a whole bunch
of pieces together this person said this
this person said that and
and understanding you know
relatively speaking where are those big
buckets in the process
included in that
director malachi it would be nice if if
we could look and maybe
if you can identify any legislative
opportunities which really is going to
be within the purview of this community
committee
if there are
unnecessary legislative roadblocks that
can be identified
then we can certainly help with that so
i think it's an opportunity
to have some discussions you know
amongst your team uh with the ag and if
you can come back and speak to that that
would be very helpful of us also
you kind of stepped out a little bit
following up a little bit on
representative wolper just kind of a
summary of resolution times really it
would be interesting to get a feel for
what is the picture when things come in
for the the normal person what are they
seeing and we talked about some of the
outliers so it would be nice to
understand okay these are outliers and
what are some of the drivers behind
those outliers is it because as you said
um we're getting amendment after
amendment after amendment are there
other things more process related
driving those outliers just so that we
can have a better understanding of that
those are some of the things i would
like to see representative smith
thank you very much mr chair i i think
that you made some very good points
when you suggested to the director that
she speak with her staff and with the
ag's office in order to identify
uh
possible
ways that the legislature could remove
um unnecessary roadblocks
i would ask that she might consider
broadening that
to um
to solicit responses from attorneys who
have represented both employers and
employees in the past
um
or
represented
it's not necessarily employers and
employees represented people on
on both sides of the issue as it's
presented to them to see if they can
identify ways
that there seem to be some unnecessary
roadblocks because if that informal
communication can take place
the impending doom of the legislature
it might be very helpful
because it's always good to avoid
representative lorenzo thank you mr cure
um one of the things that i think
should be explored is
the three-year statute of limitations
i'm wondering if there's a way
that three years
can be frozen
at the time a person files with superior
court
i think that's a question that we could
does anybody else
have
any thoughts any information that they
might want to have gathered over the
summer to help inform the discussion
yes
i could go all day but but i won't um
my
my head is spinning a little bit because
um
you know sb 2 296 was intended i thought
to be a way to ensure that all claimants
had access to
an administrative relief
or to relief period and that that
um you know specifically small claimants
needed to have the ability to stay in
the administrative forum if they were
going to get justice at all
and it seems that somehow now the focus
has shifted to
well
okay but are we providing due process to
the defendant employers which is fair
but also
are
is everybody involved in the
administrative law process
being treated fairly in in terms of how
long the process is taking
um
and
the attention they're getting in that
process right so those are those are all
of the things that i'm
i'm hearing um are being considered
right now and that's and that's fine i
just want to make sure that this that we
all
hopefully remember that this started
as
an effort to make sure
that employees with ongoing harassment
and potentially
you know small dollar valor value
claims
have a way to get a remedy because
right now
again the defendant can
play the
you know
you've gone through this process and
you've gotten close card
i'm gonna i'm gonna make you
play a whole other game at a whole other
level which i know i suspect you can't
you can't compete in
segway into
uh the discussion of the the small
number of hearings at the commission
um
over the last 10 years there's
there's been i i mean i looked on the
commission's website before i
came today there's only six
published decisions
coming out of the commission
in 10 years
so
that means that only
six cases have been
heard fully i think
and i mean we heard today from director
malachi that many of these cases
settle i think she
submitted
information today showing that about
half of them
settle well nine settled i think in two
withdrew
i want i want
you to think about
the possibility that many of those cases
may have settled
because it was communicated to employees
in those settlement discussions that
unless you settle
i'm going to yank you to superior court
so the fact that
this this shadow of removal
really um
[Music]
both directly and indirectly
affects employees access
to relief from discrimination because it
takes away a forum
that employees i thought were supposed
to
smaller uh employees were supposed to
have
when 354a was enacted
marissa asked me to talk briefly about
the due process concerns i you know i
think that if you look at the
massachusetts cases
that analyzed this issue
[Music]
after
new hampshire
gave
defendants the right to remove to
superior court
you will see
that there is no genuine due process
um
concern
that there's actually a new hampshire
a united states supreme court case
that
um
emphasizes that the right to choose form
for adjudication should rest
with the one seeking redress
and frankly the one that bears the
burden of proof rather than the one from
whom the redress is sought
and the united states supreme court
also
notes that
the possibility of defendants
um
making themselves judgment proof by
forcing the plaintiff into a forum where
he or she cannot afford to to contend
um so i can i can i'll happily email you
the massachusetts cases and my
distillation of them
in terms of the due process principles
but
i'm here to tell you today that the case
the
in in 2000
house bill 297
added the right the defendant's right to
remove
to 354-a and that was because there was
this issue
in a massachusetts court surrounding the
constitutionality
of
defendants not having the right to a
superior
court trial a jury trial and being stuck
with an administrative agency hearing
and
after we enacted that law
the massachusetts supreme court analyzed
the issue and said no no no
there is no problem
with a let with
asking a defendant to see the
administrative process
through from beginning to end through
hearing
and then giving the defendant the right
to a full appeal
in superior court if necessary there's
no due process issue
with that structure
so i i will um
i will send those cases to you if
so we would absolutely love to have
those cases um and your other comments
are not lost on on this committee uh
when
we
heard testimony originally i think
everybody
was
of agreement that the bill itself sb 296
was on solid legal footing
and so we were comfortable with that but
uh the chairman of the whole committee
representative gordon and it was a valid
point which attorney burns you
kind of reinforced where you're saying
justice
delayed is justice denied and you're
actually
removing your own clients because of the
time in this issue and so
one of the concerns that we had as a
committee as a whole
was
what what what
is this going to actually provide an
added burden on to the commission
so while we felt that sb 296 was on firm
legal standing
in practical effect we did not know what
its passage was going to bring and
that's why we have this interim study
committee so i think that's where we are
and we we want to
see that we get there but that the
practical effect is that we have
something that is working and i think
that's the goal that everybody in this
if i just might just follow up a little
bit on on what attorney douglas was
saying
because i do think it is important and i
know you gave an example of the fact
that that i for example i'm having to
remove some of my cases to the
commission so that i can get them to
court
there's a there's a smaller subset of
cases that i can handle for employees
but there's a big section of employees
who can't necessarily find attorneys to
take their cases when our firm takes
employment cases we take them on a
contingent fee basis almost all of the
time because our clients have been
terminated from their jobs and they
don't have the resources to pay our firm
by the hour to engage in expensive
litigation and court litigation has been
become very very expensive now because
of the issue of what we call esi which
is electronically stored information
which is as we all know everything we
think and everything we say we put it in
an email so we get thousands hundreds of
thousands of emails and cases it has
made the litigation process so so costly
there is a subset of employees sometimes
lower
lower level earners
who who can't get an attorney to
represent them in a case and so the only
recourse they have is to go through the
administrative process of being at the
human rights commission and if they wait
in the commission to the point where
they finally get a probable cause
finding and they think that they can get
a hearing where they'll be able to
represent themselves at the commission
to then have the rug pulled out from
under them and have them move to the
superior court system where then i can
tell you we get calls we get calls from
potential clients regularly who have
said i got a probable cause finding from
the human rights commission
and a large law firm
one of the national law firms with
regional offices here in new hampshire
has just removed my case to court and
now i find myself either in the superior
court or even the federal district court
how can i possibly do this myself and
the answer is they really can't they
can't and so right when they're on the
precipice of winning and getting
a justice for their unjust and unlawful
termination
they end up going into a system where
they cannot compete unless they can have
legal counsel and for a lot of those
plaintiffs they are not going to be able
to secure legal counsel and so if the
employer time after time can remove
their case to court as soon as there's a
probable cause finding it will deny
justice for so many of those employees
and we have seen it and that is why
attorney douglas and i are here today to
talk to you about this issue because
from our perspective it is so important
for all employees in the state of new
hampshire who want to have a state free
from discrimination
so i think we have a pretty full bucket
for the summer
and so uh with that i just
if nobody else has anything else to add
just very quickly a small note
there's a folder and i'll make sure you
get one representative smith you go okay
so inside just just because i know we're
leaving in just a moment inside the
folder on the left hand side
has the
previous white paper behind that
is what i would call an introductory
training and it just talks through
what we do and how in our and our
process just a high level version of
that on the right hand side uh all of
those forms paperclip together
that is um those are the questionnaire
so one the one we chose was the
employment questionnaire so that's
something that a potential
claimant would complete and it's
confidential and they can fill out what
has happened to them
and then that starts the intake process
i believe right behind that
i think it i think it might be the form
five which is the eeoc's form
where that is what we use in terms of
employment for a formalized charge of
discrimination and then that goes to
both parties behind that
is an intake tool kit so what we're
working towards is having complainants
complete their own charges putting all
their information together and that
document will walk the complainant
through
all of the elements and how to complete
that charge and then the last document
should be i think it's two pages it's a
damages worksheet to help the person who
and these are for people well anyone
would have access to it but specifically
for people who are not represented
and the damages worksheet helps them to
understand
what their the monetary relief that
they're asking for how to compute how to
computate that and and what uh giving
examples and and how to figure out what
they would want to ask for in damages
since we don't represent either party
and we cannot give legal advice
especially for the person who is pro se
or not represented this is our way of
being able to assist but not provide
legal advice so i just wanted to put
that out there you have those and
obviously my business card is in there
that's my direct dial i think most of
you have my cell phone number so please
all right so then this meeting is
you